[Music]
do you have a response to House
Republicans who say nine of your family
members got money from overseas
now how much longer can Joan as a White
House ignore questions like that
especially given what we've just learned
about the Biden family crime
organization now courtesy of documents
reviewed by the oversight committee
they've identified six additional
members of Biden's family who may have
benefited from the family's businesses
bringing the total number of those
involved or benefiting to nine joining
us now is house oversight committee
chair James Comer Congressman I guess
the question now becomes you know was
there any Biden family
remember not benefit fitting maybe that
dog that you know Biden tripped over
that time his family pet I mean well the
way they've set up so many llc's and so
many bank accounts I wouldn't count the
dog out I mean we just haven't gotten to
the dog yet right now we're at nine and
Counting and it's just it's worse than
what we thought we've made a lot of
progress in a hundred days we've been
able to get six Bank six different banks
through subpoena bank records on
specific accounts but what we've learned
from our most recent trips to the
treasury is there are a lot more Biden
family members involved there are a lot
more llc's that were laundering money or
at the very least hiding the the source
of the the deposits that were coming
from our adversaries around the world
and you know there are a lot more bank
accounts than what we first thought
so what what do we know about the bank
accounts and the connection to these
foreign countries well the banks were
very suspicious of where the wires were
coming from and they weren't just from
China they were from other countries and
we'll go into more specifics hopefully
next week about that but with respect to
China the banks were concerned that
these LLCs sprang up and they had no
revenue and then all of a sudden a three
million dollar wire or a one million
dollar wire popped up from some company
in China and and you know they were they
feared that these were state-owned
entities which means they were directly
funded from the Chinese Communist party
they weren't legitimate businesses so
the banks knew that something fishy was
going on and then they knew the
recipients of these wires from from
China and other countries were the Biden
family so they were politically exposed
persons is what what it's called in a
bank a pep a politically exposed person
if you're a relative of a high-ranking
government official you're a politically
exposed person and then if you're
getting wires from countries that are on
our watch list or countries that we have
sanctions against then you're going to
get a lot of Bank violations and what we
learned is a lot of bidens have gotten a
lot of Bank violations more than what we
first would have estimated well
Congressman were you surprised that
Hunter Biden ended up accompanying
President Biden to Ireland for the big
tour of Ireland they recently did it's
almost like they're back on the gravy
train again like get get get get it
while the getting's good at least
because yeah the president knew when he
went to Ireland that my staff was
already
granted access to treasury to those Bank
violations they had to know that we were
going to uncover that there were even
more Biden family members involved in
this influence peddling scheme they had
to know that we were going to discover
new bank accounts and new llc's that we
never before knew about because they
never before been reported so the fact
that they were so blatant and so
arrogant and bold to go and and parade
Hunter Biden around on the international
stage it's just another smack in the
face to any American who cares anything
about public corruption Congressman
we're going to be following this thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else